vi sentite parte con questa
presentazione vi mette st pressione
anche durante la giornata io volevo
intanto ringraziare il ted perché non
facevo merenda da 15 anni 15 anni che
non mi capitava di farla merenda allora
c'è la fine del mondo fra pochissimi
medici alla fine del mondo e può essere
una cosa positiva è anche una cosa
negativa positiva
ovviamente più facile rimorchiare le
donne no dicendo tra un mese si muore è
più facile riuscire a convincerlo poi ho
fatto una scommessa di 100 euro con un
mio amico e io sostengo che ci sarà la
fine del mondo e quindi il giorno dopo
la fine del mondo io avrò vinto 100 euro
e la cosa di cui volevo parlare del
futuro è una cosa che mi è capitata
nella vita
io ho sempre pensato che il futuro
come dire si creasse venisse alla luce
condizionato dal presente condizionato
da tutte le decisioni che una persona
deve prendere il giorno dopo giorno
momento dopo momento no e quindi è
capitato poi a volte nella vita di
trovarsi a un bivio e ogni volta
sembrava il bivio della vita non sapete
quando sette giorni devi scegliere liceo
l'università oppure mi sposo non mi
sposo facili gli vado a vivere in quella
città non resto qui ogni volta questo
questa decisione
viveva una pressione apocalittica
un'ansia tremenda e allora ho pensato
una volta qualche anno fa ha detto ma se
facesse il contrario se provassi per una
volta a vivere per un po facendo in modo
che sia il futuro
a condizionare il mio presente cioè il
contrario
e come si fa e intanto bisogna per forza
a farsi una domanda che non si può in
qualche modo diciamo saltare cioè chi
voglio veramente essere nella vita chi
voglio cosa voglio realmente fare
soprattutto qual è il mio scopo qual è
il motivo per cui io sono su questo
in questa esperienza diciamo di vita si
come ognuno di noi è diverso dall'altro
ognuno di noi avrà una verità una realtà
una sensibilità diversa da portare e
allora ho iniziato a sostituire causa
effetto con invece è principio di scopo
e vi faccio vedere la prima immagine
la prima immagine è diciamo chiamiamolo
cubo di marmo che se non è proprio
incubo no questo è un cubo di marmo e ha
già abbastanza bello da vedere così però
ovviamente quando per esempio
michelangelo farò delle citazioni di
persone in zona insomma ecosostenibili
km zero quando michelangelo si trovava
davanti a un cubo di marmo voi sapete
che lui diceva non all ottimo artista
alcun concetto che la materia in sé non
circoscriva col suo soverchio cioè io
non scolpisco in questo caso la pietà la
pietà è già dentro questo cubo di marmo
e io non faccio altro che liberarla da
tutto ciò che la in gabbia
ho cercato di fare la stessa cosa nella
mia vita ovviamente io non ho trovato
dentro la pietà è più un bidet però
comunque lavorandoci magari con l'arte
contemporanea si riesce a tirar fuori
qualcosa di interessante ma il principio
questo ho pensato michelangelo ogni
volta che scolpiva che dava una
martellata una picconata era
condizionato dall idea che aveva di
quell'opera d'arte chi era dentro quel
cubo quindi ogni sua azione del momento
era un'azione in realtà dettata da un
futuro che però era già presente era già
lì e quindi ho pensato che ognuno di noi
essendo un pentito un pezzo unico e
irripetibile ha dentro di sé un'opera
d'arte
se non per l'aspetto fisico come
macchina biologica ognuno di noi appunto
è diverso dentro c'è sicuramente una
scintilla divina che ci rende diversi
l'uno dagli altri allora anche quando
per esempio platone diceva noi eravamo
un giorno bellissimi potenti poi zeus si
era spaventato ci separa in due
siamo una mezza mela che cerchiamo
l'altra mezza
ma l'altra mezza mela non
necessariamente deve essere una donna un
uomo l'altra mezza mela e la parte di
noi come la pietà dentro il cubo che
dobbiamo portare alla luce che dobbiamo
tirare fuori in modo che non siano due
zoppi che stanno insieme nella vita ma
siano 22 unità possiamo diventare tutto
ciò che vogliamo
ognuno di noi c'è solo c'è solo la pietà
dentro quel cubo e ce ne sono anche
altre possiamo diventare tutto a un
bambino gli si può dire così in un
futuro del prof della prossima era
diciamo quella quella nuova che
consigliavano i maya consigliano di
educare i bambini educare le persone a
educare noi stessi al principio
fondamentale che ognuno di noi è
veramente speciale che ognuno di noi è
veramente unico e irripetibile e che se
magari uno non ha un talento artistico
voglio dire michelangelo quando ho fatto
la pietà ben 22 anni io sono stato
bocciato impongo in terza media quindi
sicuramente non è quella cosa ma se uno
di noi non ha un talento artistico ha
sicuramente una capacità ha sicuramente
una sensibilità ma sicuramente una
identità diversa da tutti gli altri
allora la domanda è possiamo diventare
tutto io domani mattina mi sveglio e
decido che voglio essere una ballerina
della scala e se mi applico ce la faccio
credo di no se non altro perché ho detto
ballerine non batteria comunque no
perché se tutti noi potessimo diventare
tutto e tutti noi saremmo questa cosa
qua chi sono i barbapapà i barbapapà che
sono meravigliosi sono colorati ci piace
un sacco però qual è il principio del
barbapapà al dato papa non diventa ciò
che vuole non diventa ciò che è il
barbapapà diventa la cosa che diciamo
serve in quel momento che necessita i
chilometri di serve una sedia diventa
una sedia serve un auto diventa un auto
e noi nella ricerca di sé
chi decide di fare questo diciamo
viaggio circolare dell'uomo verso se
stesso come cene l'odissea ognuno dentro
di se a volte viene sedotto dall'idea di
riempire un vuoto nel contesto sociale
oa familiare o della coppia della
famiglia e quindi in qualche modo non
sceglie se stesso ma in qualche modo per
paura di non piacere alle persone che
abbiamo attorno al quale amiamo
diventiamo ciò che gli altri vogliono di
noi che uno degli errori più diffusi ma
anche più dolorosi non solo per la
persona stessa che rinuncia a se stesso
ma perché quando una persona rinuncia a
sé tutta la comunità ne risente e allora
da qui vi faccio vedere un altro esempio
che prendo da sempre legato alla
scultura però lo prendo da un filosofo
leibnitz che dice se nel blocco fossero
invece venature che segnassero
l'immagine d'ercole a preferenza di
altre immagini questo blocco vi sarebbe
più disposto e quindi l'ercole vi
sarebbe in un certo modo come innato per
quanto fosse sempre necessario un lavoro
per scoprire queste ve ne è pulirle
togliendo ciò che impedisce loro di
mostrarsi nello stesso modo ci sono
innate le idee e le verità e ciop e cioè
le come inclinazioni disposizioni
abitudini o virtualità naturali quindi
noi dobbiamo cercare dentro di noi
quella parte che ci rende diverso da
tutti gli altri
non dobbiamo farci sedurre da chi ci
vuole diversi da noi da chi ci da un
feedback diverso da noi ma dobbiamo
sapere che sotto una stratificazione di
falsità esiste un centro una matrice
originale vera che va seguita però non
dobbiamo nemmeno noi forzarci a essere
ciò che per esempio nel contesto sociale
in quel momento viene considerato
meraviglioso quindi
è importante imparare
diciamo a volersi bene imparare ad
accettare ciò che si sa è sapere che
ognuno di noi ha dentro di sè uno scopo
che serve che serve a tutti gli altri
sono un telefono sarà platone che
sorpreso che non ho citato allora questo
questo viaggio dentro se stessi
mettiamola così questa ricerca di se può
sembrare un po un po egoistica no c'è
già quando uno dice io voglio bene a me
stesso è così egocentrico sia egoistico
egoista io credo che sia invece il
percorso naturale verso l'altro questa
sera o questo oggi pomeriggio non so più
che ore sono insomma abbiamo sentito che
c'è problema del consumismo che c'è il
problema del clima che c'è problema
dell'economia che c'è problema
tutti questi problemi e io credo che la
misura sia sempre l'uomo abbiamo visto
anche se ha parlato prima di di fashion
e visto che sono da queste parti e cito
appunto persone di queste zone
savonarola diceva cosa te ne fai del
vestito se non c'è l'uomo sotto no
allora credo che questa ricerca di sé
sia fondamentale perché quando uno è
nella propria cosa e nel proprio
elemento quando uno per vivere esprime
se stesso
invece che reprimere se stesso poco
importa tutto ciò che accade intorno che
è solo fastidioso chi se ne importa di
godere per un nuovo paio di scarpe
quando tu hai le mani sporche della cosa
che stai facendo quando qualcuno di noi
prova l'emozione della creatività perché
per sentire quella voce dentro di noi e
immaginare come noi vogliamo essere in
quel futuro bisogna prima far passare
dentro di sé un milione infinito di
immagini poi ce ne sarà uno in
particolare
che ci regalerà un brivido un'emozione
un calore e quella e quella da seguire
quindi si passa dall immaginazione alla
creazione ma non esiste un futuro reale
senza crisi se noi non spalanchiamo
infiniti futuri inediti ognuno di noi ha
davanti a sé un futuro inedito che
nemmeno lui forse riesce a capirlo fino
in fondo infatti non è che poi la
costruzione di quest'opera d'arte
finisce che uno ha 40 anni 50 anni ha
capito che nella vita no come dice anche
kakà kakà più sale i gradini e più
gradini aumentano però è la ricerca di
quel talento è così potente che non può
essere chiamato egoismo perché le
persone che affrontano questi questa con
queste conoscenze diventano contagiosi
nella vita degli altri
io me lo voglio prendere il tostapane
del ragazzo perché è una bella idea e
perché io me lo sono immaginato la sera
a licola fidanzato qualcuno che si mette
valeee e allora uno contagia ma
soprattutto quando uno dentro di sé
scopre la meraviglia per cui siamo stati
creati insomma poi dipende se uno e
religioso se invece è laico
automaticamente la incontra nelle
persone sa che quella matrice divina che
è dentro di serie la chiamo divina
perché mi piace pensarla così ma quella
meraviglia con il seme che può esplodere
dare un futuro veramente un destino
inedito differenza di un'idea che tutti
noi dobbiamo avere in qualche modo uno
stesso destino e poi c'è un oligarchia
di artisti che quelli sono stati baciati
da dio invece no allora io
parlo di matrice divina perché mi sembra
giusto citare anche dante ovviamente
dante sostiene che ognuno di noi a
questo raggio dunque nostra veduta che
conviene essere alcun dei raggi della
mente di che tutte le cose sono ritiene
quindi noi siamo abbiamo dentro di noi
un piccolo raggio che è divino che è
quello della creazione e quindi magari
viene anche da pensare e se gesù non
fosse dio che si è fatto uomo
ma se fosse un uomo che attraverso
questo portare al di fuori
l'opera d'arte questa unicità questa
mezza mela diventasse di vino e allora
siamo tutti nello stesso figli di dio
nello stesso modo
e allora tante dice a volte le persone
cercando questa sensazione questa
unicità non la trovano e quindi vengono
sedotti da altre cose no perché la
materia
segue altre regole quindi
dall'ispirazione al desiderio alla
realizzazione c'è un tempo diverso e lui
dice che quella cosa lì che ognuno di
noi sa e se qualcuno di voi in questa
stanza pensa di non esserlo speciale
vuol dire non che non lo è ma che è
stato educato male nel senso che non è
stato esposto a degli stimoli affinché
questa unicità potesse uscire pensate
che addirittura un linguista chomsky
forse il più grande linguista della
storia ed è ancora ed è ancora vivo io
ho avuto la fortuna di incontrarlo
l'anno scorso addirittura nella fine
degli anni cinquanta scopre che il
linguaggio nei bambini non lo imparano
mettendo dentro ma dentro
ovviamente per platone era al mondo
delle idee ma dentro il cervello c'è
come dire un neuro biologicamente una
struttura fatta per poter esprimere
quindi il linguaggio persino il
linguaggio è già dentro
lo so che è tutto molto platonico quello
che sto dicendo quando faccio queste
citazioni comunque e dante dice quella
cosa lì c'è ed è come il fondo del mare
quando tu stai arriva il fondo del mare
lo vedi quando tu vai all'arco il fondo
del mare non lo vedi ma c'è
semplicemente l'uomo fa fatica a credere
alle cose alle cose che non vede alle
cose difficili e quando una persona non
segue questo percorso che porta diciamo
una sorta di luce propria noce nel senso
nord che mi si illumina d'immenso ma di
luce nel senso di indipendenza
un'indipendenza emotiva un indipendenza
creativa un'indipendenza di ogni tipo e
quindi se non c'è quel sole
certo che possono entrare tutte le
lampadine del mondo no perché in una
stanza dove non c'è il sole l'abat jour
diventa il sole in una vita in cui uno
non riesce ad esprimere se stesso in cui
non è libero qualsiasi altra cosa
diventa una cosa importante immaginate
un l'ora d'aria
voi siete tutte persone libera parte
oggi vi siete qua inchiodati fino alle
sette siete tutte persone libere
immaginate se io domani vi dicessi che
voi avete una sola ora d'aria come i
carcerati sarebbe una grandissima
condanna se io facessi questo discorso
in un carcere e dicessi da domani avete
un'ora d'aria partirebbe un applauso e
quindi è importante nella propria vita
non vivere mai con quella sensazione di
essere stati piegati a un volere che non
è il proprio sto per finire e quindi vi
lascio con una cosa che mi piace tanto
se noi
uscendo da questa stanza non ci
chiediamo realmente cosa vogliamo essere
e chi siamo realmente
e se non ci interessa e scavalchiamo
questo percorso di conoscenza di se non
ci sarà un reale futuro ma sarà sempre
una una cosa zoppa perché il futuro e
quando questa matrice divina che noi
abbiamo dentro tutte si incontrano
allora lì sì che vedremo il volto di dio
nel senso vedremo una realtà più chiara
la cosa importante è anche che
quell'immagine che voi creerete dentro
di voi di voi nel futuro e quindi quel
futuro sarà qui a condizionare le vostre
scelte
quell'immagine potrà anche cambiare nel
percorso perché non importa non è si può
lasciare anche spazio i nuovi sogni
purché si segua un percorso una voglia
di andare dentro di sé e allora c'è
stato un bambino 35 anni fa io
devo portare milioni e milioni no non è
vero però sono a decine e decine di
storie ne ho scelta una che forse quella
più come dire è stata molto di cronaca
quindi è molto attuale
un bambino 35 anni fa si sveglia una
mattina va a scuola e decide di fare un
disegno la maestra dice cosa disegnate
sogna i vostri sogni fate un bel disegno
lui disegna se stesso che vola con un
paracadute
l'avete visto in questi giorni
sicuramente sui giornali lui disegna un
paracadute è ovviamente quello nasce in
lui quel sogno e non lo abbandona mai
nonostante qualcuno gli abbia detto
probabilmente adesso fatturato per
supposizione guarda che è pericoloso
qualcuno magari ha detto ma non ti
conviene lavorare imposta che c'è anche
la tredicesima e stai tranquillo ma noti
ma perché ti sei messo in testa poi
quando uno parla del proprio sogno o lo
parla a gente che affronta al proprio
altrimenti diventi presuntuoso ma come
adesso arrivi tu che sei il meglio di
noi parla come mangi vai qui è tutte
queste cose
tant'è che poi in quelle vite la
felicità non è mi è esploso qualcosa
dentro ma come stai ma tutto sommato in
un mi lamento non è successo niente cioè
la mancanza di dolore prende il posto
della felicità
questo bambino disegna questo questo
paracadute e contro tutta una serie di
condizioni esterne che gli fanno capire
che quel sogno lì che cos'è il
paracadute ce ne sono milioni di
paracadutisti e non c'è niente di
importante in più anche pericolose
perché lui insiste e 35 anni dopo quel
disegno quell'uomo fa il salto col
paracadute più alto della storia del
mondo e se nessuno ha mai fatto quel
salto lui ha rotto la barriera del suono
da 35.000 metri rompere la barriera del
suono e tutto il mondo ne è contagiato
perché quando uno realizza un sogno
reale diventa appunto contagioso negli
altri tutti gli altri ne godono e per
questo quando uno rinuncia a se nel
puzzle finale fa un danno a tutti
quell'uomo ha fatto questa cosa
questo il disegno del bambino con la
mamma i fratelli sono sempre belle le
proporzioni dei bambini
la mamma alta come la casa e la casa un
po più alta della bottiglia e quell'uomo
35 anni dopo ha fatto questo
vari file
questi
le api
io
richard sera
tutti destinati a creare un futuro
inedito altrimenti non ha senso
grazie